vous donne la parole les émissions c'est
vous qui les fait et nous on sera juste
là pour vous écouter et retransmettre
tous à un petit van planté au beau
milieu de cette place avec un studio et
des animateurs ce jeudi après-midi les
micros sont ouverts pour les habitants
lorena a choisi de lire un texte qui
parle même de temps en temps elle est
amusant et des fois un gars saute quand
le quand elle s'occupe des affaires des
autres
franchement c'était bien des bleus jules
par mais franchement c'est plein gré ici
on parle de touffes des histoires de vie
des anecdotes on chante aussi parfois
des moments conviviaux retransmis sous
forme de podcast sur le site internet du
média vans donc on a été numéro à
notre table qui tient l'atelier
d'écriture c'est ça surtout là en plus
on est en sortie sortie confinement ils
ont énormément de choses à dire sur
n'importe quel sujet j'ai même vu une
émission de cuisine semaine dernière
avec une dame qui veut nous présenter sa
recette de cookies donc c'est assez
sévèrement de coups alors ils ont ils en
ont besoin ils sont d'avoir d'avoir
parlé aux autres l'idée derrière ce
projet crée des liens susciter des
rencontres et faire sortir les habitants
de leur quotidien
l'initiative du projet c'est de
permettre aux habitants qu'ils partent
pas en vacances de pouvoir bénéficier
d'activités tout au long de l'été en
fête et qui puissent bien faire des
choses pendant l'été donc le principe
était vraiment là et puis c'est aussi
d'animer le quartier puis c'est aussi de
faire venir des gens dans le quartier en
fête
le média vans sera encore présent jeudi
prochain dans le quartier du vernet
toujours à saint-amand-montrond
l'occasion de libérer la parole de ceux
qui ne l'ont pas forcément